I  believe that to truly slow down,
you have to change the way you travel.
Cycling allows me to travel more fluidly,
to connect more deeply with my surroundings
and, I hope, with the people
who call this place home.
I'm Michael George and I'm a National
Geographic travel photographer.
I'm exploring the Scottish Borders by bike.
Myjourney will take me from the heart of this region
out to the North Sea coast.
I'm curious to understandmore of the area's history
and how the region inspired the
legendary writer, Sir Walter Scott.
Well, welcome to Abbotsford, home of Walter Scott.
Built this home himself with
the proceeds of his writing.
Disaster struck when he was a toddler
because he contracted polio
and because of his infirmity, he was quite lonely
and his imagination was fired
with all the stories of the Borders.
Shall we take a travel back in time
and I'll give you a littlebit of introduction
to this great house?
Sure.
It's like a beautiful chaos.
I think that'sa wonderful expression.
"A beautiful chaos" is absolutely correct.
but most importantlyperhaps are the
shields that go round the ceiling,
because these are the shields
of the families of the Borders.
You have this wonderful view
of the magnificent River Tweed.
Scott was an environmentalist.
Looking afterthe landscape was
something that was very important to him
and of course many of thesemagnificent trees,
we see in the natural landscape,
were possibly planted by Scott.
We don'tknow which ones
but we can just be grateful.
With this gratitude in mind
I head further intothe incredible
cultural tapestry of the area.
There is a warmth and honesty to the
people even in your first meeting.
It's as if you've known them all your life.
You arrive a stranger but leave a friend.
The Scottish Borders is a place that feelshidden.
Everything seems to be tucked away.
But traveling more slowly allows for
gentlerplaces to reveal themselves.
The ruins of ancient abbeys,
beautiful bridges across theRiver Tweed.
Each place with its own magic.
Moving through the ever-changing landscape,
woven with reminders of the region's history,
I am moved by how deeply
connected the peopleare
both to the past and to the present.
Peel towers, fortifications originally built to
protect the people from invasion and capture,
are now perfect for capturing a photograph.
An ethos of conservation is evident here
from Scott's dedication in planting trees
to today's wildlife preservation at
St. Abb's Head National Nature Reserve.
Hi there.
Hi Michael. How are you doing?
It's niceto meet you. I'm Ciaran, I'm
the ranger here at St. Abb's Head.
Yeah, it's so nice to meet you.
You too, yeah.
The sea's nice and calm so just keep an eye out for dolphins and whales
and so even at this timeyou can see Bottlenose dolphins quite close in.
Oh amazing.
Yeah.
So, St. Abb's Head is a really heavily designatedsite.
So, it's a national nature reserve which is one of
the core purposes is to connectpeople and nature
and protect the nature as well.
Yeah.
The reasons why this site is designated
is for its assemblage of wildflowers.
So, if you come in midsummer there's
like carpetsof pink thrift
and a sea of yellow from various flowers,
rock rose and gorse and... yeah, it'sbeautiful.
So, we've got an amazing grey seal colony
here, so in just a couple of weeks time
the firstpup will be born and from the little lump
of land up there and back to this beach here
there'll beover eighteen hundred pups born on the beaches.
So, in the summer the sea birds take over.
So, theycompletely fill the stacks. The noise, the smell is incredible.
But we get about 60,000 seabirds here
and really is an assault on all your senses.
So, I kind of feel the responsibility on my
shoulders to protect and conserve what's here,
to try and provide the habitat and try and protect
it fromanything that's going to damage it, or harm it.
The Scottish Borders is a place
with many stories to uncover.
If you want to know more, it's as simple as asking.
But to get the full story,
you'll have to slow down.